>> Yeah, so let's look at this example and the different parts of it
in some detail. So what I'm showing here in green are the four different
components that were generating as a virtue of this assembly specification. And
as I mentioned a minute ago, the only one that's the, the, the variant,
the one that were interested in is batch. But the other three, bFsct, mults and
iFsct are all kind of sub components that are used to, to, to create batch.
You can think of a component as a little program.
It's clear that batch is a little program. It's a little forecaster but each of
the other ones is a little program too. iForecast is an incremental forecaster.
Mults is a set of multipliers and bFcst is a baseline forecaster.